Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
Yeah, back in 'Bama with this beast again.
This is our new favorite beast.
We just had to use it for another video.
In this video, we're gonna simulate
what it might be like
to get sniped in the eye
with a .50 cal sniper rifle.
Just so you don't have to.
Just so you don't have to
go through that yourself.
We're gonna use the V2511
and a mirror placed at 45 degrees.
So we don't actually have to
shoot the Phantom in the face.
Full sun, you good?
All right, Dan, give me
your best and only shot.
I think we're good.
Well, you broke the mirror.
Yeah.
Wow.
Goodness, one second the mirror was there.
I looked again and it was just gone.
Were you nervous at this point?
I just wanted to get a
shot right, you know,
didn't wanna miss.
Ooh.
Can you see the bullet?
It's coming straight--
That is the bullet.
That dot in front of
the smoke is the bullet.
Wow, so--
It's just is gonna get bigger
and more soft until it hits the lens.
That is terrifying,
I've never seen a bullet
just not move in any direction
apart from towards it.
Yeah.
Ooh, right in the middle there, jeez.
Goodness.
Wow.
That was a damn good shot.
That's the light at the end
of the tunnel right there.
God, you think you'd hear
the shot that killed ya.
No you wouldn't.
Probably not.
You wouldn't know anything about it.
It just looks like it disappeared.
That's so weird, I guess,
because I was focused through the mirror,
but you were the same distance
away as that burn behind it.
You can't see the edge of the mirror.
It just blurs off.
Oh, oh right, so wait.
So they're both in focus?
What's in the distance
and me.
You were in focus
and what's behind the mirror's in focus.
When I first saw it, I didn't even realize
that the edges of the mirror were there.
Yeah, completely, look.
And then it's hard to tell
that the mirror actually
didn't fill the frame
but the blur made it look like it did.
It looks like in some
sort of weird valley.
What an unexpected side effect.
And it's an amazing shot
And also it was an amazing shot.
Ah thanks, yes, good job and good job.
Well done, well done.
Thank you, sir.
Well Dan, that was absolutely
terrifying high speed,
I thought.
So scary,
imagine that.
If I've learned anything
from this video, it's don't get sniped
by a .50 cal sniper rifle.
Did you need to learn that?
I feel like I already knew it,
but now I definitely, it's
like a hundred percent
at this point.
Yeah.
This is Destin's sniper rifle.
If you would like to watch
more content with this beast,
head on over to Destin's
channel, SmarterEveryDay,
'cause he's doing .50 cal
against bulletproof...
No, no, no, here you go.
I had is made.
Where'd you get that?
Oh, it's got his name.
Ah, what?
If I can't have a new one.
You can't have one at all.
Give me that, take it off, come on.
Oh, it's got poppers too.
It's even better than ours.
All right, whatever.
Go check out Destin's channel.
Give him a little sub.
I'm taking this.
Thanks for watching.
Yeah, you can just change,
scribble out "estin"
D, Dan.
and put "an".
"An" yeah.
You could just scribble out "esti"
and put an A there.
D, yeah!
There you go!